i've heard that you you speak about
co-parenting and i'm i'm doing that
right now too
it's tough it's is it is it is it harder
than you thought like
you know is it working with you
interesting because it's i know with me
and brandon it's just a difficult thing
because we're in different places
and it's like we both agree on like the
main things but it's a hard thing when
you're not together all the time
for me personally um has it been hard
for you
you know my parents were the most
perfect example
and i i was really blessed and fortunate
to have that as my example and to see
that and even with my
stepdad and the integration of all of
that and how my dad and my stepdad
dealt with one another was really just
such a beautiful thing to witness they
played golf once a week and i'm sure
that wasn't easy for my dad but he did
it for us
um and so having that really selfless
example was awesome for us so i think
with all of us whether it be courtney
and scott or tristan and myself we
definitely
i try to mirror that and always keep it
about the kids
um but with tristan it's a trust thing
and tristan
is so great and really trusts me as a
mom and knows i'm always gonna
do the right thing for true so he really
doesn't
tell me no a lot of the times and i'm
grateful for that because i think as
moms we just sort of feel like
we have the right to like we know what
we're doing with our kids
yeah but um it was fun the other day i
wanted true was going to be three in
april and i wanted to give her her very
first
trim and when i mean trim like not even
half an inch i just wanted to cut some
of her baby hairs
and tristan i don't think has ever told
me no and he really freaked out
by me wanting to cut her hair and i just
i was
so crazy to me how he was freaking out
he called my brother for my brother to
talk me out of it
he called my mom i was like oh my god i
wasn't gonna give her a trip if you
i didn't know he was that adamant about
it until everybody else started calling
me
but um i didn't do it because i i also
have to
you know show him that i okay if you
don't want me to do something that badly
i'm not gonna do it
yeah so it's just i think great with
communication and
trust is the most important thing i
think with raising kids
yeah absolutely i think you're right too
i think that's what brian and i focus on
too is like
if as long as you make sure it's about
the children in their best interest then
we're both
on board yep i'm still here just waiting
for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever